all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my morning coffee thoughts
for I give my thoughts over morning
coffee today I have bone broth
avocado strawberry and banana in my
smoothie
kind of fire if you ask me so today
I was inspired by a tweet I saw on
Twitter
now I want to say
this is no shame to that individual
content creator okay
I'm just going sometimes people on
YouTube are a bit or in Twitter are a
bit weird if you like criticize their
ideas you think they're coming for that
I don't look
but I saw this tweet from a guy named
Gavin
and he said the modern Workforce is
absolutely destroying Woman as a man it
is your moral duty to become rich and
save your mom and girlfriend and family
from this hellscape
and then Leia commented also hi Leia no
shade just a different point of view
okay how can you call yourself a man if
your mom is still working
and I respond and I say
do we have the same energy for
non-virgin women
now why do I keep going back to the
Virgin they're like Pearl are you
obsessed with virginity no
okay
I just think it's ironic it's a little
bit
ironic in this times okay
because we essentially this is what
Society is like
into right now oh my gosh
all right we have the Kings
the peasants
and the concubines
now this is really what has made up
Society now why do I call the women
concubines
because when I say Horrors it's a little
everyone starts yelling at me and
they're like Pearl well are you
now I will say there's a difference
between a modern and a historical
now it seems like today you become a
over 10 bodies okay that seems to
be the modern definition of a woman
only fans you're officially a
if you accept money for sex or you
guys get the deal
foreign
you know modern women have really tried
to get around this by like you know just
sucking a bunch of guys
and then their body counts lower or like
lying about body count you know to fit
the modern definition of what a is
however
from a historical point of view I came
to the realization
that we're really lucky to be living in
this time period because at any point in
history a woman that didn't wait till
marriage really was considered a
and you know if we're gonna think of
like I have a marker here sometimes I
just like to see it we're going to think
of like a traditional outcome right like
what is traditional
the man gives protection
providing
the woman gives purity
youth okay like this is the typical
ex I know my handwriting is trash but
that's the typical exchange right
but now the women
they're not virgins so Purity gone I
don't care if it's one body
one other man would have been considered
bad okay youth were over the age of 25
is expired in China we're going by
historical points of view
so if you're over 25 I know this is a
hypocritical if you're over 25 you are
not giving youth anymore it is gone NADA
you're just lucky to be alive in this
time period so
and I thought about this
so he's saying he's saying offer
the traditional
um aspects of protection and
provisioning and I would say most men to
some extent provide both right we all
know when a woman makes money
there's a reason the men are like it
doesn't matter because you don't give it
to us so
most men are paying the majority of the
bills most men are stronger than most
women
so you could argue maybe they don't
provide like they did in the past
um but you could also argue that the
women want a much higher lifestyle in
the past like this idea of women getting
their nails done their hair done new
clothes every year guys like women used
to sew their own clothes it's so funny
when I see and I know I have
I I don't get my nails done that often
but you know we have them done it's so
funny when I hear women like harping on
me about you know my looks because
really historically
you wouldn't have been that fussed like
traditional women aren't that fussed
with their looks they're not buying new
clothes every week they're not getting
you know their nails done like
traditional women worked on a farm
and if you want to look at what I would
say is a more traditional woman think of
the Amish are those chicks taking
selfies every day do they have their
nails done Etc no
so he's saying provide
TR you provide the traditional aspect
and if you don't you're not a real man
and the women
um
but he's basically saying provide
traditional outcomes to because
if your girl sorry if your girl is not a
virgin traditionally she would have been
a
so and I was thinking I was literally
thinking about this I'm like who's more
of a simp the guy that says no no ma'am
you did not wait till you were married
therefore you do not deserve a
traditional outcome
um or the men
that say well you know I know you slept
with Bob Tom Dick Harry but I'm still
gonna treat you in a traditional way I
would argue that honestly the guy paying
for everything is a little more simply
now I'm not even saying don't do that so
please do not misconstrue this for me
saying don't pay don't like obviously
it's better for the family if the woman
stays home but I was thinking the best
outcome for society and sometimes guys I
really think hypocrites
are the best because you know I can
acknowledge that this would screw me
over
but it would be better for society if
all the men if top men got together and
said hey we are only marrying virgins
like if Brad Pitt wanted a virgin you
don't think he could get one
and what it would do is if the men held
out for like five years the younger
women would look and say oh
you see what's happening to these old
ladies we don't want that and they would
adapt but the problem is we see too many
women
having no consequences Alex Cooper
caller Daddy
zero consequence
um this chick Logan almost married zero
I mean I we'll see if he still does but
zero consequence so it's like why would
women change Sierra like why would women
change if we see all these examples of
women in the media and remember we just
do everything for whatever propaganda is
in our ear for whatever reason don't
know why
you know if all the men and said hey
we're gonna we're gonna take care of you
for a lifetime we're gonna protect you
but
you have to marry Young
and you have you have to be beautiful no
fatties and you have to be a virgin that
would be a fair exchange but it's kind
of funny because it's like we're in a
modern world
and yet even Trad cons are still arguing
provide traditional outcomes for
and you say pearl well they didn't say
in particular they said good
women well
unfortunately your good woman is still
historically a and it's so funny I
was thinking about this I was like okay
the modern so let's talk about the
modern horror because there's a
traditional in the modern horror
and the the modern horror seems to be a
girl that slept with 10 less than 10
Partners but we're gonna go less than
five today we're gonna go less than five
um less than five
and
um I'm trying to think of what else
would be a traditional woman or like the
modern non-whore
yeah less than five partners and no only
fans no provocative pictures on
Instagram and I was thinking I was
literally thinking about this and I'm
thinking
really five is still a lot
I know not in modern times but I'm like
so you guys are arguing all right the
good woman slept with five men instead
of 25. now I know 25 is like a lot a lot
but five is still
like think about that five dudes in a
room
and
you know or four or even let's go down
to three it's like okay three men or 13
men
I mean at some point it's like what's
the difference now there's a big
difference I know please don't come for
me and be like aha but it's like
okay
I know people don't like this word now
part two of this thought
yeah
I thought it was interesting how again
he's saying you're not a real man if you
don't pay for basically if you
don't pay for everything
and I really had to really think about
this because you know
it's really funny because we're in a
modern world like people used to live on
the farm
and so women
used to do farm labor like imagine your
average chick that you know sir if it's
so funny because I'll see these chicks
on Instagram talking about how they want
to like live on a farm
and I'm just thinking no you don't no
you do not no you don't you have to
scoop poop you have to scoop chicken
poop like you gotta get so remember the
women back then were serving the Met
they were cooking from scratch
um
and I'm not just talking about putting
salmon on a on a
on a skillet you know what I mean I'm
talking like in-depth two-hour long
recipes right from spread from scratch
all this stuff and they were on the farm
do you want farm work milk and cows like
I want you guys to YouTube Amish woman
and a day in the life of the Amish and
look at those women and ask yourself
could you do that
and I'm going to be honest with you guys
right now where I'm at in my life I
would have a really hard time I'm a hard
worker I think I could learn
but to act like I
have the same willpower as these women
don't so it's funny because I'll see
these chicks like on Instagram taking
selfies
um talking about anyways
sorry off track off track Pearl goes on
tangent
so when I was thinking about these guys
that make a lot of money and most of the
guys now that on the internet that I see
make a lot of money are typically
bitcoiners
um they sold some sort of course
or they make money on YouTube and I have
to say us YouTubers we really live in la
la land
now what do I mean by that we somehow
found
a way to make money by just talking
and I will never think of myself as
better than someone because I
talk for a living
or I
traded crypto or Bitcoin but I looked up
the average salary of a coal miner
so I looked up the average and it was
like 30 000 pounds I'm in the UK so
and I thought
okay so that's like an average salary
and nowadays you need two incomes and
I'm like are you telling me the coal
miner
that has his chick work a part-time job
while the kids are in school
is now not a real man and it's funny too
because I hear these guys saying just
make more money make more money make
more money and it's so funny because
none of the guys at the top none of the
Kings could make it without the peasants
so the coal miners the bus drivers yet
they will on the men it's like it's
funny because the guys that somehow
figured out how to make a lot of money
doing something in my opinion that's not
a ton of work I think a coal miner does
is a way harder job than any guy talking
on the internet than any guy
you know
um or oil rig same thing any guy you
know trading Bitcoin okay like it's a
different skill set but one just happens
to be paid more but it's funny because
the guys at the top will will kind of
on the peasants you know the guys
at the bottom and say well you should
like you need to make more for your wife
you need to do this for your wife like
you need to make sure she gets this
traditional outcome and fair enough
but is she a traditional woman if she's
not a virgin sorry lady like I'm just
really tired of women calling themselves
traditional when you didn't wait till
marriage because that's that's the
traditional woman
and even the women that did wait till
marriage most of them could not survive
a day with an Amish family
much less years like they couldn't do it
now am I saying it's wrong to do any of
this no please don't conflate this with
me
telling you how to live your life
or telling you not to have the mom stay
home with the kid but sometimes I just
think it's funny because we'll shame men
for not meeting traditional standards
but we never shame women for not meeting
traditional standards and if I ever
point this out I'm curious
because I just tweeted this
um if I ever point this out it's like
then I'm the bad guy you know what I
mean and I would argue that most men
like a coal miner guy whose wife has to
work part-time
he's still providing he's still
protecting but what's he getting in
return
and I was thinking about too
most women send their kids to school
so it's like after the age of five most
women have two kids and then they send
them to school so it's like after the
age of five
what are you really doing all day like
it wouldn't kill any Chick to work
part-time a couple days a week to help
the family I'm not saying do that but
I'm like
and it's funny it's funny so
um
I want to see because typically
you know
it's it's just it's funny because we
shave one and not the other and that is
my point and I will not take these
tradcon guys
seriously
until they start bringing into the
conversation that women have to be
traditional because until you say that
the woman has to be a virgin you're
really just encouraging simping and I
hate to say it I hate to say this
doesn't help me guys but this is just
the only logical conclusion I have
because it really is simping to have a
chick wear a white wedding dress and pay
10K for a wedding to a chick that's
banged two other dudes three other dudes
it really kind of is simping if you're
telling a woman
oh I'm gonna take care of you completely
but you're not really bringing
anything in terms of Purity and Youth
sorry guys this is just this is how I
think
yeah so I don't know maybe I'm just
crazy maybe I'm wrong I don't know and
I'm I'm welcome I'm open to the
discussion so if you could convince oh
and I was thinking too but it's not
simping when a girl waits like three
four years to marry you
serves you for three four years and then
you know basically like does everything
for you then it's not simping because
he's like all right before the ring lady
I got all this like all this value up
front because I'm not getting the
previous value and that's kind of what
we're seeing now so
you know
guys let me know what you think in the
comments I'm open to the discussion
maybe Pearl's wrong and I'm just a woman
hater but this is just how I think and
sometimes sometimes
I'll advocate for things that don't
necessarily benefit me personally so you
know like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and let me know
guys you know give me your responses let
me know if I'm wrong